- [Veronica] Oh well,
karma's a bitch.
(dubstep dance music)
- [Narrator] Okay.
What just happened?
Well, let's back up.
This is China,
and right now, there's a
trend happening in China,
where people on the app,
"Dou Yin" are recording
themselves transforming.
Normally, the trend
features a cryptex remix
of the songs, "Gucci Gucci" by Kreayshawn,
and "I Got" by Beats Antique.
Legally, we can't play those songs,
but, that's okay, we'll make this work.
But on top of everything,
there's the all-important
soundbite from "Riverdale".
- Oh well,
(dramatic music)
karma's a bitch.
- [Narrator] Now, people
all over the world
are trying the, "karma's a bitch" meme.
- [Veronica] Karma's a bitch.
(dubstep dance music)
So, we thought we'd try it for ourselves.
- So, I didn't know much about
this, "Karma's a bitch" meme.
- My friend actually sent
me a YouTube compilation
of the meme on Facebook, and the next day,
saw it on BuzzFeed.
- And I watched the video.
I was like, "well".
- It's so
fucking cute
and wholesome, and so
simple and straightforward.
It's literally just
like: here's me one way,
here's me another way.
- I love a good reveal.
Who doesn't love a good reveal?
This is why magicians, and,
like, drag queens are famous.
- We don't, in America, or
like, in the Western world,
usually see that many memes from China.
So I think it's been
really fun to see the,
you know, like, Chinese humor go around.
- I'm so glad that there's room
for just pure internet joy in 2018.
- I'm so excited to make
the, "karma's a bitch" video.
It's going down.
- [Narrator] Last question.
- Yeah.
- [Narrator] Are you ready?
(dramatic music)
- I'm ready?
I think?
(inhales deeply)
- [Veronica] Oh well,
karma's a bitch.
(dubstep dance music)
- [Veronica] Oh well,
karma's a bitch.
(dubstep dance music)
- [Veronica] Oh well,
karma's a bitch.
(dubstep dance music)
- [Veronica] Oh well,
karma's a bitch.
(dubstep dance music)
- [Narrator] So Matt, how was that?
(laughs)
- It was so hard.
It's hard being cool.
- That was interesting.
- That was really fun!
I'm not gonna lie.
- It was my dream to become a panda.
- You just kinda believe in yourself.
Then you're like, "hell
yeah. I'm fucking cool."
- It boosts your confidence
in the little bit
of time that it takes to do,
so go ahead and do it, man.
You'll be surprised.
(groovy jazz music)